when it comes to food festivals it is
one of the best and it is back we are
talking to drewie who plays martin and
the rat pack is back about what's going
on the sponsors of this next san gennaro
feast welcome
how did all these people get in my room
i i feel weird calling you drew even
though that's who you are because you
are just the spitting image of dean
martin i feel like am i drooling no
you're not drooling but maybe i am a
little bit i'm so sorry
the san diego feast i feel it's like a
tradition in life it is a tradition and
it starts again not only in vegas but
it's everywhere it starts tomorrow here
in vegas tell us at the end resort the
um resort this year that's right you
just drive there you park and you go in
it makes it so convenient what do you
guys have going on what what do you guys
have going on there oh we got all kinds
but there's food
there's a lot of food we got we got
italian sausage and peppers we got
linguini and clams we got shrimp scampi
is that what's your go-to where do you
go first when you walk into st
pizza we got pizza we got pasta pasta
pasta and more pasta and then after that
there's pasta and we got funeral cake i
mean funnel cake and then
all kinds of goodies and the rides yeah
the rides go on the rights first and
then eat the food afterwards i think no
no you like to eat first
grease
snow cones cotton candy then you go mix
it up in your stomach
54-inch high kids and
lower are free that you that'll make for
an interesting time but i actually kind
of like that idea and mercedes there's
going to be a lot of good entertainment
you are included in that i'm really
excited about the entertainment because
your lineup is crazy and if you've never
seen drew perform before amazing rat
pack is back
who else is going to be possible there's
going to be a lot of people i wish i
could remember
i don't know anybody we don't have your
drink with you you said you needed to
remember without my drink we've got um
so many david perrico we have david
perrico's raiders house band yeah
great band we got the rat pack is back
we're going to be there friday night if
you want to see that i do around 9 30 we
got
what else we got we got zoe bowie zoe
bowie chris phillips yeah we got chris
it's good you got your notes i know i
just well i remember because i want to
come see you perform i'm wondering if
you can give us a little we got a great
blues oh really janice joplin cosmic
blues
it's a tribute to janice joplin all
kinds of good stuff going on there and
when do you typically hit the stage hold
on we can't forget mj live michael
jackson will be there oh my gosh this is
going to be the same franchise great
best one for the for the ages we're
looking forward to that you're beautiful
so are you
sure
i can't get my eyes off
well when the moon hits your eye like a
big piece of pie
when the moon hits your eye like a big
pizza pie that's amore oh i'm getting
hot in here when the world seems to
shine like you had
too much wine that's amore
we
[Laughter]
you're amazing thank you so much for
friday you guys are going to t
d-u-e-t that's the duet i'm talking
about that's what i was talking about
what were you talking about what you
talking about
this is crazy san gennaro feast of the
ambrose sword is coming at town uh we we
are so excited to see you perform and
i'm getting really warm over here i'm
going to send it to you goodbye
everybody